yeah it's also very confusing
you know it's hard to figure out yeah i
never wanted to write about bitcoin it's
interesting and had it not been the
winklevoss twins i never would have you
know over the years people have pitched
me stories about bitcoin
you should write about bitcoin i was
like i'm not interested in that the word
blockchain is like the worst word ever
invented
it's like math it's horrible um but then
you see these two giant twins
billionaires out of the blue and they
were the bad guys in the social network
well suddenly you've got a great story
and that's the whole reason i ended up
writing it
and are those guys still in silicon
valley didn't know they're new york
based
they're based in new york so after no
one would take their money in silicon
valley they headed back to new york
which is where they're from originally
and you know they're from connecticut
but their their father was part of wall
street and that's where he made his
money
so they ended up being you know a part
of that whole thing and so their their
offices are in new york city
and uh and uh and they're doing very
well they have tons of employees and and
uh
they're worth many billions of dollars
what did you say the company was called
again
gemini gemini yeah didn't zuckerberg try
to make another company that
yeah it's really funny the winklevoss
twins launched gemini and then a couple
years later a couple uh i guess a year
ago
uh zuckerberg announces that he's going
to launch his own cryptocurrency
and he's calling it libra and so to me
it seems like way too much of a
coincidence that the twins would have
gemini
and zuckerberg would have libra and so i
envision that as much as the winklevoss
twins wake up every morning with their
hatred of zuckerberg
zuckerberg wakes up every morning with
his hatred of the winklevoss twins
i feel like there's this there's this
connection of anger between them
that is never going away um libra ended
up
not happening yet we'll see what happens
with that i think
facebook is not trustworthy people don't
trust it enough
to to to have it hold our money you know
it's already got our data and our photos
in our lives
do we really want them to be our wallet
and i think people got very nervous
about that yeah
definitely and did you guys make the
movie for bitcoin billionaires
billionaires is gonna be a movie um it's
basically uh it's set up greg silverman
who used to run warner's is
producing it and uh and it's gonna be
really really cool i
i you know hollywood is frozen right now
so when things reopen i think we'll get
moving on it but uh we have you know set
up the movie yes
this brings me to the most
fascinating topic that i want to talk
about with you
which is uh aliens
and ufos i love us can we talk about
that stuff
of course um your book's called the 37th
parallel what is the
37th parallel can you explain what the
significance of that is
yes the 37th parallel um
is uh well let me go back a little bit
okay
um the reason i got into the story uh
about
ufos and and i'm from a family of
scientists my dad is a scientist
my brothers are both scientists um i
never really believed in ufos i'm as
skeptical as as one can be
um i got a call from a hollywood
producer
who said there's this guy in colorado
he's a sheriff
his name is chuck zukowski and he was
just fired from his job
um because uh he'd gone to investigate a
cattle mutilation
so cattle mutilations is this really
strange phenomenon
happens all over the midwest um where
cows are found
lying on their left side missing their
organs
usually they have cuts on them that are
circular that look like they were cut by
a laser
the cows are completely drained of blood
there's no footsteps
there's no you know footprints there's
no evidence
um and this is a phenomenon that goes
all the way back to the 50s it was such
a big deal in the 70s so many cows were
being found like this
that three governors got together and
demanded an investigation
there was an investigation by a hundred
fbi agents and they
found nothing not a single shred of
evidence
um so chuck zukowski was a cop he was a
sheriff's deputy
investigating one of these weird cattle
mutilations he was looking at this cow
and he started to think ufos so he went
to the police station you know
and he said uh he started to say i think
this is related to ufos which sounds
crazy right
he was immediately fired um and he
became
obsessed with the idea of ufos and he
started studying
all of these ufo sightings and he put
them
all down on a graph and he discovered
that the majority of ufo sightings occur
along the 37th parallel of the united
states which is a line that runs
across the united states latitudinal
line
he also discovered that almost all
cattle mutilations are along the 37th
parallel
it also turns out that almost all uh of
america's
military bases secret underground ones
are on the 37th parallel
the united states from cheyenne valley
all the way um
across to um that's also dependent on
it's also where yeah i think
historically that's also where a lot of
nuclear testing has been done right
a lot of nuclear testing has been done
along there it also turns out there's
somewhat an underground cavern system
around there
there's lots of strangeness around the
37th parallel
so chuck zukowski called it the ufo
highway or the ufo superhighway
i went out and started hanging out with
him to write this book 37th parallel in
the process of writing it what i
discovered
was that there's a lot of weirdness
going on in the world of ufos
not the people who know about ufos who
are usually pretty weird
but the us government has been studying
ufos for a long time
and this just recently came out so it
turns out what i wrote in the 37th
parallel many years ago
is now actually coming out in the new
york times um
but the us government never stopped
investigating ufos they pretended to
stop after project bluebell
in the 1950s after roswell and and that
whole story
but what happened is they ended up
outsourcing it
to a company called bigelow aeronautics
a guy named robert bigelow and this is
all true
he's a billionaire who lives out in
nevada who runs a major aerospace
company
that has deals with nasa they make the
inflatable
gaskets that are used by the
international space station
well it turns out robert bigelow has
been studying ufos
for many many years in conjunction with
the us government
and in fact if you look at an faa manual
of what u.s pilots are supposed to do if
they see
a ufo or something they can't understand
they don't report it to their airline
because they would be fired they don't
report it to the us government because
the government is not officially
investigating ufos
they report it to robert bigelow this is
right in the fba manual
and so it's this really weird situation
where a private billionaire
who makes uh things for spacecraft has
been
secretly and privately investigating
ufos
um for 30 to 40 years now
sorry sorry sorry i just wanted to go a
little bit
a little bit more on on bigelow how did
bigelow where did he come from where did
he get his money
and how did he start a kid uh in in
nevada
who had uh uh become to believe in ufos
when he was a little kid
and his mom had he was in a car with his
mom
and there was some weird sighting on the
road um so
as a kid he'd seen bright lights he'd
seen you know whatever
um as he got older he made his
fortune in hotels he was a real estate
guy it was a i really was travels budget
suites of america
was his um once he made his money he
decided to pour
half a billion dollars into into
essentially ufo studies
he created something where he hired all
of these actual scientists
put them together and said we're going
to study ufos because the weird thing
about ufos is nobody's allowed to study
it
if a real scientist starts to look into
it everyone calls them crazy
if if a journalist decides to write
about it everyone calls him crazy
and what's interesting is this dates
back to the 50s when the pentagon
and the u.s air force uh um decided
and there are memos about this that the
best way
to cover up their own research into this
phenomenon
is to ridicule anyone who attempts to do
it so
back then when there was a conference
about ufos the us air force would
actually
send someone to the conference to
essentially make it a big joke
and to to mock it to get up on their
yeah or these are
little green men yeah that whole thing
was that was a was a a double
speak mission to make it hard to
investigate
because they were actually investigating
it for a different reason they believed
it was the russians
so uh the us government back in the 50s
believed that roswell was the russians
um that believed that any of these
sightings you saw was black ops either
by their own
division or by russian spies and so they
had reason to cover this up that had
nothing to do with aliens
but that carried forward and so every
time a navy pilot sees something
it immediately gets covered up um not
because they are hiding aliens from us
but because it dates back to the 50s
when we were hiding russians from us
um and so it's an interesting phenomenon
and so very recently
the pentagon is now releasing these
files saying that there are things we
don't understand that there might be
vehicles that we're now saying are not
necessarily of this earth
um you know that's really weird but
i i if you read 37th carl i get much
more into detail into all of this
and it's quite fascinating yeah it's
super fun it's a super fun subject
and it's it's a cra it's a crazy subject
just because that
there's i'm going to move rooms is that
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely
yeah yeah no what i was going to say was
it's such a fun subject and it's such a
it's such a weird subject to navigate
just because
there are so many crazy people
that are super into ufos and
studying and looking into aliens and so
many of them are full of [ __ ]
it's hard to sift through all of these
people
and yeah i mean that's the interesting
thing is that so 99
of ufo sightings are not ufos 99
is is a you know a flare a drone
some sort of military thing or nothing
at all
and and there's a lot of people who see
something and their entire life changes
and
and they they go down this route um
because it's easy to go down
you know we want to believe we want to
believe in conspiracy so badly
everybody wants to believe it you can
see it happening today all the time with
what's what's going on with kobit
conspiracies are our bread and butter
we're our our minds are
made to look for these patterns right
that's how we got out of the jungle in
the first place